hello someone enter Samuel Leeds I'm
property investor on the best-selling
author of the book by low rent hi I've
been investing in property for over a
decade and I've helped thousands of
people with my property investors crash
course and right now on YouTube I'm
going to be answering your questions
about property from last Sunday's video
so while I'm answering these questions
if you've got a question that pops into
your mind
comment it below and next Sunday I'm
gonna be answering your questions so
comment any questions you've got about
property below anything at all or if
it's about finance tax how to get deals
where to buy what to buy when to buy
take them out of service accommodation
lease options we would anything comment
below I'll do my best to answer make it
a specific personal question to you the
more specific the better and also don't
forget to smash the like button if you
enjoy my channel please do subscribe
turn the notification belt on and keep
your questions coming let's see so last
week we had Bushra who said would you
buy a property now yes I would buy a
property now as long as it was in the
right area and at the right price 100%
Ben Parkinson rent 2 HMO or rent 2
serviced accommodation ok so right now
that's a really good question
right now I'm extremely excited about
service dicamba Dacian just because so
many people have handed the keys back to
service accommodation units so if i was
going to do rent to hate you more rent
to serviced accommodation right now
probably rent to serviced accommodation
as much as HMOs on my first love and I
do think hankie mothers are gonna get
more popular over the next sort of 6 12
months but right now I think rental
service accommodation is absolutely
popping because so many people have been
disillusioned with it during the
lockdown alright Carolyn says heist time
you love you enthusiasm in all your
videos thank you so much I'm about to
start out on my first project to
becoming financially free which is
converting my parents house to a 7
double bed hm oh good for you that
sounds awesome
is it better to split the profit with my
parents to lower the income tax paid oh
and do you mentor one to one if not
what's the best way to find one when you
don't know a lot about about who you
were doing successfully in the property
market thanks for your feedback and
keep it real thanks for your message do
I want to one mentor yes I do want to
one mentor and I do that through Samuel
365 if you go to Samuel 365.com
it's 95 pound a month and I do mentoring
I have a team of mentors and I think
you'll find that really helpful but to
answer your first question which is
should you split the profit with your
parents to the low lower the tax income
paid okay first thing I'll save this yes
it will lower the tax income because if
you're making money from a 7 bed hey
Chan oh and you take half the money you
give parents half the money of course
you're gonna pay less tax because the
more you own as an individual it's like
a sliding scale so the more tax you pay
however my advice don't make a decision
based on what's going to save you the
most tax you need to make a decision on
what's going to make you the most money
so don't just say oh we'll split the
profit because that will save more tax
no you're going to think what's going to
make what's going to be the best deal
the fairest deal what's going to make
the most money also you say you just
find out this is your first deal if
you're just I own property if you're
going in property full-time as long as
you've not got any other income sources
you don't pay a penny tax on your first
11 thousand pound profit so and then
after that as way if you've got a
limited company you're gonna pay you're
gonna pay yourself and in eleven
thousand pound wage so you don't pay any
tax on that and then you're going to pay
yourself in dividends and for the first
30,000 pounds and dividends you're only
going to pay 7.5% tax which means you
could be on a forty thousand pound
salary and you're going to be paying
peanuts in tax so I probably wouldn't
worry too much about that right now
I just be thinking about how do I make
this deal stack I don't make sure that
there's money in the deal rather than
letting the tail wag the dog the tail is
the tax and the dog is making money
hope that helps great question mark next
Jeremy says hi Samuel I appreciate the
content incredibly helpful thank you I
appreciate that I hope you're a
subscriber
during the corona virus pandemic we saw
tens losing their jobs and being allowed
not to pay rent or get evicted would you
advise adding legal claws of some kind
to tenancy contracts to protect against
tenancy
lose their jobs during future pandemics
hopefully there won't be too many future
pandemics especially we went to rent
where landlords aren't likely to get
mortgage breaks from the government as
it's not their mortgage but the owners
how do I want to protect themselves
while still being fair to tenants in
tough pandemic pandemic unemployment
situations cheers Jess thanks for your
question Jess listen number one I hope
that there's not going to be plenty of
pandemics this is the first pandemic
like this I've ever had in my lifetime
and I've spoke to people that are much
older than me and said the same thing so
can you get in your tenancy agreement
that your tenant has to pay rent
regardless of a future pandemic to be
honest I'd probably think no because if
there's the reason that tenants didn't
have to pay their rent and it's not that
they didn't have to pay it they don't be
under no illusion tenants had to pay
rent during the pandemic it's just that
if they were behind on rent and they
weren't paying rent you weren't allowed
to evict them in the middle of the
pandemic lockdown and to be honest I
think that's fair because during the
lockdown and the pandemic situation and
Bhabha this whole tenant thing this was
only over a few month period I think
it's still going on right now but this
isn't at all for the next two years
during the heat of everyone losing their
jobs everyone being furloughed everybody
being absolutely freaking out and not
knowing what they're allowed to do
people not allowed to see their families
being stuck at home with no Gardens a
lot of the time it's all the government
saying is yeah now's not the time to
evict someone if you've got a tenant
it's not paying their rent just give
them a bit of grace until lockdowns
finished then they have to pay the rent
then they have to catch up I think
that's reasonable and whilst it's a pain
for a landlord I just think you've got
to be fair and you've got to look at
you've got to look at what's fair and
also on top of that not many of my
tenants didn't pay rent
most of my tenants continued paying rent
because they didn't want to be evicted
as soon as the lockdown finished so
jairs probably wouldn't worry too much
about it just be a good landlord being
good communication with your tenants and
you'll find that even if there is a
future pandemic probably most of them if
your tenants are like my tenants will
continue paying anyway next George Griff
says I'm looking to buy
too bad property in Croydon where
they're planning to build a Westfield in
the near future is it better to buy an
ex counsel flat in less than a quarter
of a mile from the town center or about
five miles away in a better area jords
Croydon Croydon I think it depends on
what the ROI is you're talking about how
they're planning to build Westfield in
the near future I personally wouldn't
worry too much about that because what
they're planning to do in the near
future that doesn't pay you any bills
right now so expected capital
appreciation is good but it's a bonus
what needs to happen is the deal needs
to stack up and it's the cash flow and
put money in your pocket every single
month so my advice would be to buy the
property that's going to put more cash
flow in your pocket right now from rents
rather than trying to think too much
about the the capital appreciation
cabins depreciation is good but it's a
bonus again don't let the tail wag the
dock next I can do you think rental
service accommodation will work in
current market conditions yes because
they're reopening the market and
everything's all getting back to normal
and in fact a lot of people of that were
doing rent to serviced accommodation
handed the keys back to the landlord so
I think now is the opportunity 100% yes
Noddy says I love property buy-to-let
but not money how I love property if I'd
slept but not money does that mean but
you haven't got money or you don't love
money I hope you love money because
buy-to-let is going to give you money
how can i buy well if if you've not got
money and you want to get to buy-to-let
there's lots of different ways number
one is you can raise the finance you can
get the money from from an investor an
angel investor you can get it from a
bank you can get the money raised lots
of ways just raise the money if you
haven't got it number two is you can
make the money you can what be creative
make some extra money and save number
three is you can do a joint venture and
you can find a really good deal and you
can get somebody else to put the money
in and you can go 5050 S on the profit
number three is you can do a rent to
rent where you control the property we
don't own it therefore you can get
started with very little money
number five is you can do a lease option
agreement where you can buy a property
now but agree to pay for it later in the
meantime you can take the monthly cash
flow and you can you can benefit from
the capital appreciation and exercise it
and a later day when you've got the
moment number six you can
these deals and passed them on to
investors and be a charge of broker fee
in the middle like there are so many
ways just depends on what tickles your
fancy but just choose one go frigging
make you happen okay well we got next
Adrian hi Samuel I'm currently 17 years
old hustling and doing car washes to be
able to get insured etc to be compliant
as said from your video a year ago I'm
glad that you've been watching me for so
long would I still be able to deal sauce
without being insured Adrian if you're
gonna be dealing with investors and
you're gonna be finding deals and
passing them on to investors and you're
not insured the danger of that is if the
deal goes bad and they try and sue you
it's not pretty
you're 17 years old it's good that
you're thinking like this it's good that
you're saving up it's good that you're
washing cars my advice would be to find
someone who is insured find the deal
sourcing company that's selling deals to
investors approach them and say what
kind of deals are you looking for find
them a deal and pass them a deal let
them sell it for you let them deal with
the investor let them be the one that's
responsible and it is insured but you
ask for a commission fee so let's say
you find a deal that would sell for
three thousand pounds typically you say
to the to this company
I found the deal I've negotiated the
deal I've got it from an estate agent
I'll pass it to you you sell it we'll go
5050 S on the profit you made fifteen
hundred pounds boom then that fifteen
hundred pounds save it put it in your
bank and use that towards education to
invest in yourself and use that towards
setting up your compliant business if
you're coming in short that's what I
would say good luck man massively good
luck all right last one
Joe says hi Stein you're referencing
buying houses rather than a house to
avoid stamp duty is it as simple as this
obviously for every house you buy you
can set up a limited company for next to
nothing shortly that'd be way too easy
okay Joe I think you've slightly
misunderstood I think what your question
is is you're saying if you can avoid
stamp duty by buying through a company
why don't you just set up a company buy
a house set up a company buy a house
it's not quite that simple because you
don't void stamp duty by buying through
a company you only avoid stamp duty by
buying a house that's inner company
instead of buying the house you buy the
company
that's how it works there's other ways
to avoid paying stamp duty as well like
buying a property that is going to be
serviced accommodation I've ever served
accommodation right now you're gonna pay
commercial stamp duty tax which is
nothing cup to a hundred fifty thousand
pounds you could avoid stamp G by buying
your property that's inhabitable and
it's inhabited but if there's no hot
water so if the boiler is broken and is
not really fixable and you need a new
boiler guess what the house is not
habitable you don't paste and gooey so
there's other ways to avoid paying stamp
duty I hope that helps guys thank you
for watching the video I know so much
about property because I've been doing
it for so long and I just love sharing
my knowledge on YouTube and helping
people with tips tricks to become
successful in property ultimately to
become financially free like I did if
you like my videos please show some
support and some love by subscribing
also smash the like button and drop your
questions and next week I will answer
them thanks so much see you next time
[Music]
you
[Music]